éric bérubé les maires génération
terrain de la commune roche molière
bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france alors vous pensez
vous de cet amendement proposé par le
ministre de l'intérieur ce qu'il ya là
une volonté de vouloir contrôler les
élus locaux
alors c'est important de toujours se
dire le rôle des mères avec les préfets
dont avec l'état est indispensable il
faut vraiment qu'ils aient un travail
conjoint collectif pour avancer et ce
sujet très important
on est dans un pays laïc on doit
respecter les règles de notre pays et je
pense que ce que gérald darmanin propose
c'est plutôt une concertation une
décision collégiale avant d'aller dans
des directions comme on l'a vu récemment
là pour vous ce n'est pas le début de
fin l'expression d'une volonté en tout
cas de vouloir contrôler les maires
alors je ne pense pas c'est pour
justement éviter les dérives sectaires
au ou cultuelles à l'extrême c'est
surtout pour construire ensemble notre
république
évidemment on voit que l'argent public
normalement pour nous élu maire de
proximité on doit l'utiliser pour
entretenir les lieux cultuels pour les
rénover les entretenir mais dès qu on
construit un nouveau évidemment qu'il
faut en parler à l'état en parler au
ministère de l'intérieur et au préfet
pour ce sont des sujets sensibles il
faut vraiment qu'on soit en amont de
cette réflexion et de cette construction
qu'on doit avoir avec les services de
l'état
et sinon on va sur des dribbles ou
effectivement on va donner de l'argent
pour faire un lieu cultuel avec une
arrière pensée politique pour aller
tendre la main à sa cause de lecteurs
vous faites allusion à quelles dérives
cultuelle précisément puisque on sait
que cet amendement
intervient à la suite de ce qui s'est
passé à strasbourg où le conseil
municipal a voté pour une subvention de
2,5 millions d'euros pour l'extension
d'une mosquée c'est une main tendue
cette communauté d'un d'une équipe
municipale alors qu'ils sont à voir une
neutralité on est dans un pays laïc on
doit avoir une neutralité en tant qu'élu
une responsabilité pour notre république
c'est indispensable que l'on que l'on
soit vigilant à ce niveau là c'est 1 1
un indispensable si on ne peut pas faire
autrement vous comment commence
justement le le conseil municipal à
strasbourg aurait dû à agir à ce niveau
lequel processus vous vous auriez vous
auriez plaidant en faveur de quel
processus justement pour permettre
l'extension d'un de cette mosquée alors
moi j'ai déjà eu qu'un ou ma proposé sur
ma commune de réaliser une mosquée et on
me demandait un terrain et des
subventions je leur ai expliqué que la
loi est très claire on est dans un pays
laïc donc ya pas de terrains mis à
disposition d'une collectivité pour pour
ce type de projet sauf si c'est un
terrain qui est ouvert à tous il réussit
et le financement des lieux cultuels de
mon point de vue n'a ne pas y avoir
d'argent public
ou alors ça demande des bas ça demande
réflexion sa demande d'ouverture et il
faut évidemment que les services de
l'état rentre dans les discussions pour
que tout soit transparent et de façon
peu importe plus cultes mais il faut que
ce soit qu'un être nous sommes un pays
laïque et
à nous de garder ces valeurs qui sont
indispensables dit quel que soit le lieu
de culte quel que soit le but c'est
pareil pour tout le monde alors on a une
particulière en france
une particularité avec la loi de 1905 où
effectivement on a des lieux de culte
qui sont sur notre but
et la commune bois l'entretenir de façon
indéterminée
eh bien ça ça fait partie de nos
traditions de notre histoire eh bien on
l'assumé qu'on entretient les lieux de
culte qui sont rentrés dans le giron
public et municipales depuis cette date
là et ça c'est notre rôle c'est non
c'est notre mission mais un nouveau lieu
de culte doit avoir tout un processus de
mise en place qui doit respecter des
règles et tout est encadré et l'argent
public doit être utilisé pour la
collectivité en règle générale et là on
rentre dans un domaine privé du domaine
de l'intimé et c'est pas forcément le
rôle d'une collectivité de financer un
lieu le cultuel savait aussi que la
situation visée par l'amendement n'est
pas la même que celle qui s'est produite
en alsace où la loi de 1905 sur la
séparation des églises et de l'état ne
s'appliquent pas là justement les
collectivités publiques peuvent financer
peuvent subventionner des associations
cultuelles
oui effectivement l'alsace est un
dispositif assez particulier en france
où il ya des choses très particulier on
ne se fasse que chez les notaires dans
les chambres de métiers etc
c'est il ya des règles qui sont bien
définis spécifiquement en alsace
néanmoins je pense que son territoire
français on doit avoir de bon sens les
responsabilités de respecter la laïcité
juste une dernière question sur la
collaboration que vous évoquez entre
d'une part les élus locaux et les
préfets alors c'est indispensable
on voit que c'est une polémique ne
serait-ce qu'au niveau de la gestion de
la crise sanitaire les gens cocody de 19
oui et pour ça que le dialogue entre le
luron leur mère préfet est un rôle une
quoique transmission indispensable pour
que tout fonctionne il faut vraiment
travailler en collaboration étroite avec
les services de l'état et les
collectivités
rien n'est jamais simple mais dans le
dialogue et la concertation on peut
arriver à trouver des solutions et je
pense que ce rôle de mère préfet est un
rôle indispensable et incontournable
il faut donner du pouvoir aux élus de
proximité
il faut aussi avoir de l' écoute auprès
des services de l'état pour faire du
service public de proximité du quotidien
et qui est notre rôle nous sommes les
fantassins la république on va trouver
des solutions au quotidien sur nos
communes et on a besoin des services de
l'étape pour le faire de façon efficace
merci beaucoup à vous eric d'arrivée
d'avoir répondu en direct à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes marc
génération terrain de la commune
roche la molière